[Music]
today's question comes from kate and
oregon my husband and i are on baby step
two and are getting close to baby step
three he has recently started selling
things he owns in order to upgrade to
something more expensive for example a
new bow for hunting he sold his old bow
but the price of the new one was over a
thousand dollars
more than he got from the sale of his
old one he's an avid hunter and i want
to support and i want to be supportive
but the amount we have spent he has
spent in the last year on hunting gear
alone makes my palms sweaty he argues
that he is within the rules since he is
selling something he's already had but
the new purchase is always more
than what he gets from the sale am i
overreacting to this
um no you're not overreacting kate you
guys are still in debt
you're getting close to baby step three
but until you guys are out of baby step
three you are selling things in order to
get the cash from the sale to put
towards debt not to go
buy new stuff so no i don't think you're
overacting i think he's wrong in this um
he can
still hunt with the things he has uh and
still enjoy the hobby but you don't have
to go and and purchase new stuff right
now where you guys are at i wouldn't i
would wait till after baby step three
then he can upgrade some stuff if he
wants uh but he needs to sell stuff in
order to put that money towards debt or
towards the emergency fund not to
buy something new
that's the
exact correct tactical answer on what he
should be doing
the problem with this is not what he
should be doing the problem with this is
why
he's acting like a little boy and you're
acting like his mommy
he needs to man up
and decide that you and that the two of
you as a couple like two freaking adults
are trying to accomplish a goal together
and then he doesn't have to run whining
for permission to buy
a bow to go hunting
he needs to be participating in the
vision of the household
and once he decides that the two of you
are trying to accomplish a goal that's
worth it then it turns around the other
way and we start selling guns and
hunting gear and i'm a gun guy and i
have way too many of them
my wife is a purse woman and she has way
too many of them but none of those
things are getting in the way of our
future vision that we have for the
ramsey household as a couple
because that's more important than a
bunch of crap
purses and guns and bows and stuff that
we all collect
okay
so no it it's not about how can i how
can i still be anything and keep the
rules no you don't want to keep he's not
i'm not breaking the rules no you're not
participating in the grown-up discussion
is the problem you need to get your
button gear i know but whatever
participate in the grown-up discussion
yes but he's not the one asking the
question but that's the point i mean so
the point is kate it's not it's not can
we throw a blow a whistle with a striped
shirt and throw a flag he's out of
bounds he's out of bounds and not the
bow that he purchased
he's out of bounds in the fact that he
even wanted to purchase the bow because
he's completely not plugged into the
bigger picture the future the vision for
this house and this couple
that's where he's out of bounds so
that's where i'm throwing the flag
and that means that no you don't upgrade
your hunting equipment when you're in
debt
good god
no
and i'm not listen i'm all for you
getting your stuff guys i want you to go
do stuff i go do guy stuff all the time
i believe in it i think that's a big
deal and if you want to go hunting and
that's great
go hunting but you got a bow
and it wasn't the lack of a bow that
caused you to miss that last deer it was
the fact you didn't crawl up on it right
that was a problem it was you not the
it's not the arrow it's the guy shooting
it so there we go all right man he's
just i can't i think well i mean no i
mean this is
this here i know i hear i hear you and i
agree i totally agree okay but listen
there are people all there are there are
millions of people right now and i bet
half of
whatever half of them are thinking that
i have a spouse like that though i have
a my wife won't do it so the point is
you got to give you have to talk about
not the the discussion is not about the
bow yes the discussion is about the
vision and the lack of it but if he will
not then that's a marriage issue that's
really deep because you are married to a
little boy and not a man you're married
to a little princess and not a woman
because you you step in beside your
spouse you put your shoulder in the
wheel and you lift to go do the things
that matter for your house
and instead of just like how little can
i get away with or she won't nag me
oh my god what are you in a sitcom
i mean go have like a re this is no no
no this lack of vision
uh from either spouse it doesn't matter
yeah you're right it's and so your my
point is it's not a it's not a hunting
gear problem
it's a vision problem and if you can't
solve that then you really at the core
of it you have a marriage problem
because i will never tell you in any
circumstance to babysit
your spouse
uh you know well you if you're married
to a woman like that you just have to
enjoy making money no you have to quit
being a wuss
and deal with the problems of her
behavior and you all look at each other
and go this is not causing us to win
and and she's just that way you're just
a wuss deal with the stuff
you know and and it's not being mad at
you but that you cannot dance around
it's like you know how can i um
how can i manage our household in such a
way to prepare for divorce you can't
you get divorced it's a freaking
financial nightmare
i mean marriage is ground divorce is 50
grand you you can't half but do this
stuff because it's all this personal
finance is more personal than it is
financed yes all intertwined all
intertwined and for couples though you
know it's
you know a lot of people they don't even
have that discussion of what's the
vision of our of our of our household
where do we want to be like that's not a
that's not a normal discussion for a lot
of people so but the encouraging thing
is to sit down and and push into the
awkwardness like right like if you've
never had that discussion it's going to
be awkward it's going to be fun like
you're not going to know exactly what
you're doing but start the conversation
start talking about it because to your
point it's not just the money issue
your marriage changes when you guys get
on the same page and so there's
something about changing the marriage
and the outflow of that changed marriage
comes
situations like a money situation that
you guys then work on together but but a
lot of people that even sitting down and
having that discussion that doesn't
those don't those discussions don't
happen
in some households so
and but
you cannot fix
the hunting bow discussion with a
hunting bow answer
because the hunting bow discussion is
not the problem it's the symptom yep yep
the problem is we're not both being
grown ups aimed at a big noble goal
that's big enough to cause me to put my
my items my selfish thing that i want to
decide for a few moments so that we
accomplish some bigger goals and my
marriage yeah and that's selflessness
that's a yeah and that's how the heart
of marriage that's how marriages get
healed all the time in financial peace
university yep i mean i've had people
tell me for years you know we've been to
six marriage counselors and then we went
through fpu and it saved our marriage
because we force you to have a vision
for the future together
we're gonna be up in your grill